citizens of the reject Nation we did not intend to
match today but here we are matching with our RR
apparel Roxy there's something we have to clear
up right away yes I know they're dating they're
dating but at least I sensed it you sensed it
I was late to picking up on it and apparently
they were dating the entire time and we had
no idea can we watch them make out or what
I don't know I even worked on the edits I was
like I don't know where did I miss this final
piece of information if you're not making out
are you even dating that is true depending on
the age range anyway we got five and six to go
through so ladies and gentlemen you know what
to do like this video leave down your thoughts
below of if you went to hell would you try to be
best friends with Satan also subscribe and click
that notification get notifi when reaction for six
is up here on the Chanel I have edited this one
and also full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page thank
you all been joying we getting a lot of pledges
from this show I really appreciate it oh that's
dope dope so good it is so good gregas
a good day and hell baby let's go let's
go oh might be Satan dad beat dad Charlie that
is the the best indicator they're dating right
there why am I why are we feel like we watch
your back feel like it's so obvious I've been
up all night trying to figure out why the hotel
isn't working we've done trust Falls oh my God I
feel you girl we only have a couple months left
before the Angels come home a beautiful mind but
Satan style maybe it's time no two ass don't say
it your dad the Lucifer he let the extermination
happen they just had a meeting and said go ahead
and kill everyone I'm sure he had good reason wait
that's it kill everyone get me a meeting with
Heaven didn't we already try that with Adam he
was an [__] but a great musical number you got
Daddy Issues no we just have never been close she
of course has daddy issues he calls only if he's
bored or or like needs me to do something daddy
issues mhm that's it almost there oh I have no
idea what Lucifer is going to be like presenting
the magic testicle back for flipping rubber
duck oh my God she's more like him than we would
realize hold the Applause please okay not what
I've been picturing no not at all daughter calling
oh um uh hello Charlie this is the most unexpected
turn ever especially after just watching Luci has
to be perfect hey [__] you know where I am
Dad I've told you before you have oh well you
know I um I love his phone case just forgot
you know I've just been really busy you know
with um important things oh he puts her off don't
do this Dad maybe you saw our commercial you know
I haven't been watching much TV lately scrambles
the brain what a trickster kind of a big ask yeah
seems like a deadbeat but like a nervous dead beat
I need to speak to heav I need to go to the top oh
no look dad I don't ask you for
much I never have but this love
Alder expressions in the background
and I need you they're behaving more
like a couple now I know I know inviting me
over my daughter wants to see me take that
depression mood this is such a choice we are
going to get this place presentable and we are
going to make an amazing impression Vos I thought
like Charlie would be the odd duck which she's so
much like her dad you could see how they're
father and daughter Charlie hey Dad oh it's
so good to see you and yet she's so off-put by
him the apple on his hat is hysterical he's even
shorter than her that must mean that Lilith is
tall girl wow this place sure looks uh uh-huh
uh-huh cookies falling oh what in the Unholy
hell is that oh he's judgmental add a bit of
color don't you think and you are Alister the
one doing your daddy job you are much shorter
in real life it's a purposeful choice I was
just saying people tell me that all the time
I guess that's why Charlie called it the hasb
been Hotel it was actually my idea well it's
not very clever oh f you Zing good one without
aliser we wouldn't have been able to pretty it
up this much give Alistair the respect
he deserves I'm waiting for Alistair to
really mess up I am happy to fulfill her bizarre
request so far alistair's been awesome thank you
Alistair we're all very proud of her is he going
to ask for his like think he's trying to show to
the dad he's closer with her than the dad is
this is vaggie she's my girlfriend they just
establish their boyfriend and girlfriend
I mean girlfriend and girlfriend hello I
clean nicely done all right then oh here we
go looks like you could use some help from
the big boss of Hell himself oh my God great with
a punch of a this feels like totally we can't be
seeing the whole thing right now you know you
get the family right thanks D who needs a bus
boy now that you've got the chef yeah you see
it coming out of him having a bus boy doesn't
eliminate having the chef those are two very
different jobs who's been here since day one
see who makes you chuckle with an old timey pun
your executive producer oh remember when I fix
that CL today's trying to get thank you sir you
what is his motive he's competing but for what
exactly done that I wish that I had what it's
a little funny you could almost call me dad oh
[__] and remember him and Lilith were gone for
the same amount of time I've always thought Lilith
sent him or something happened there true violin
versus the pianos they say when you're looking for
assistance pick the PA of least resistance
good job in your needy no substitute for
Pure they say the family you choose is better
what a bunch of losers you B out of my song yeah
singing it I'll finish it oh you tacky piece of
yes it's me what what a GU a while but oh my god
did you know she was coming no who oh oh thought
it was L me too so you two know each other oh yeah
we go way back ran in the same circles when we
were alive oh interesting that's the first time
we've seen that right right actually indicated
towards it your highness you got to warn a girl
when she's in mixed company Charmed I'm sure like
it's so interesting how they've done him where
can a girl get a drink around here my my is that
Husker really feels like a saloon how you been
furball good until 5 minutes ago yeah Savage get
him what you been up to girly fighting bugs and
uh how's that going for you they're winning but
not for long yeah get him Nifty he's been here a
while and is still a big creepy mystery what's
his deal he appeared in Hell suddenly Making a
Splash quicker than anyone had ever seen I could
see that wanted to dismiss him soon Overlord start
going miss him bars no one knew what happened to
him until these strange radio broadcast started
going out I love the oldtime radio aesthetic do
you think somehow he's working for the atams of
the world maybe but Underneath It All he's a total
sweetie poor a couple thinkers a Ry and he becomes
a kitten he just got an ego and pride you don't
want to wrong him once we have the proof that
Redemption is possible this whole hotel will be
full of demons oh my God he just doesn't believe
in her you've been gone a while and it's not like
anybody knows why and don't you worry your fuzzy
head about it what is Big Talk for someone who's
also on leash yeah what did you say [__] nothing
I um oh no I don't like when husk is scared I
will tear your soul apart and broadcast your
screams for every other disrespectful Rich
Jesus I am so interested in Alistair always
nice to catch up what is up who's leash is he
on is it Lilith but when you're gone for seven
years in hell I mean that feels like such a short
amount of time s years in Hell well it's a blip
on the radar but where'd you go there's nowhere
to go like they must have thought he was one of
the ones they killed look I love that you want to
see the best in people but these Sinners you know
they're just the worst Heaven is not exactly as
carefree as you might think messed up our people
are awful they got gifted Free Will and look what
they did with it everything's terrible feel like
I recognize his voice people like jeez what now
well like that bibsy we know you're in ah she's
dodging these guys I may be in trouble with
some lone shocks actual literal interpretation
you build something nice you invite people in
and offer them everything and they just bring
violence and Chaos that's exactly what happens
to real rejects who'd that happen with Greg I
don't want to embarrass you on camera a reminder
to all not to mess with the radio demon he is the
coolest jeez jeez he's almost what I would have
thought Lucifer would have been though Sinners
are violent Psychopaths hell bent on causing as
much pain and destruction as they can so that's
what warrants you to get in Hell defending
this hotel it may be a bit more sadistic but
he's doing it for me how come he have in
but my own father can't right sorry about
the mess but I'm sure the little bug can take
care of it got to get out of her I think you
should go Mimsy yeah you don't actually give
a [__] about this tacky place do you don't
you dare you need to leave have fun with your
little princess and your little hotel see if I
can what is alistair's motive can't I can't
figure it out whoever's leash he's on is why
he's here doing this Heaven never listens
they didn't listen to me they won't listen
to you oh my god valid baby he was a fallen
angel didn't know but maybe she doesn't know
fullys sing it baby he tried
now you're the only fighting
for you hav't been you haven't been fighting for
her it's got a great
voice where you been this whole time when I
I was young I didn't really know you at all
a baby Charlie the red cheeks on a baby is
so cute but I heard your stories looks like
Joker what's with the
duckies she's so much like
him Lilith was tall they gave her no face
just for this memory yeah they were like
we're not ready to choose or does she even
remember what she looks like I need to
save why do you care about them so much
looks like the Apple doesn't fall I've
missed that smile alistair's not going to
like this or is this alistair's plan push
this
whoa like this is father daughter song is great
you don't get [__] like
that look at these circus
performers who would have thought you get such
a touching song Lucifer see aliser is watching
with a smile aliser always has a smile will
you be okay I'll be fine that's my girl the
piano medley you ready I'm ready cuz you'll be
with me my girlfriend cuz we're lovers in heaven
yay oh boy that one felt like the shortest one
yet even though it's the exact same runtime yeah
just it flew these episodes flew lie they do they
mostly because the show is sick I'm not shooting
this part later I'm shooting this in the immediate
moment cuz say hey guys thanks for everyone who
bought a bunch of shirts from reject naations
shop.com in the year 2023 it continues to do
so in 2024 Roxy showed wearing this tea and I was
like yes I was also wearing this tea and I said I
could change into one of the many that we own
but I think it'd be funny if we both wore the
same t-shirt and the joke was hilarious could not
stop laughing guys there are so many shirts that
we have and each one you get is a wonderful
contribution to the Chanel I'm grateful that
everyone who re B if you already bought one thank
you buy yourself another if you haven't bought
one what are you doing I don't care if your bank
accounts in the negatives go more negative it'll
be for a good cause it's an investment in your
comfort what's more important than that that's why
I'm in debt to Sony massage parlers anyway guys uh
thank you so much and um hey you know what if I do
a crop in I'm just going to continue I was going
to say to for the review kicking off what was the
first thing I said uh in episode here it is that
was a surprise that was real surprised I thought
he'd be the most like intimidating imposing one
but he's a sensitive Angel sensitive Fallen Angel
and I like the approach to him because uh you
know usually Lucifer's portrayed as like the
bad boy right and they really leaned into he was
an Angel who didn't like the way heaven was being
run and they've been building up Heaven at you
have have you seen the show Supernatural parts
of it oh wow you're not a TV girl CW Show with
the brother there's like 45 Seasons you haven't
seen any of it parts of it okay well I'm on season
13 right now oh my God no way and they're I don't
want to it's really good it's the one that I with
the two brothers right yeah yeah Jensen knackles
and J P um and the there's an element that comes
in pretty really on and stay throughout the show
about heaven and they they do have a sim a thing
there where they portray Heaven I was like Angels
aren't so good you know they you can't really
trust these guys and they have a some strict
rules and [__] and it was the first time I saw
something that was really showing oh yeah Heaven's
always portrayed as like this beautiful Pleasant
Phil but man they must be as heavy enforcers and
what I liked with the Lucifer portrayal was
he seemed like a guy who didn't like the way
perhaps the draconian ways go down in heaven and
was trying to find and was trying to lean into
the Free Will aspect and help out uh with like the
people on Earth and stuff but then this came to be
like the way he the way he lamented about uh to
Charlie with like look we gave these people Free
Will and now look what they turn into like he had
good intentions he wasn't just a troublemaker and
I I find that to be really surprising and it
makes sense because I always thought Charlie
was just ah you're the odd duck you know in the
family you just happen to turn out to be this
like great caring woman but your dad's the evil
of all evils and apparently not well the way that
they depicted him in the pilot though we knew he
wasn't going to be the evil of all evils I felt
I felt you know it's actually the first episode
not the pilot no in the pilot the first episode
when they do the backstory oh no I thought it was
in the pilot when we hear when we hear about the
fact that he was the Fallen Angel and they first
mentioned that she was the daughter of Lucifer
and Lilith and we hear a little bit about it
it was episode one wrong scene I don't want to
embarrass you there was no mention of Lucifer and
the pilot there was but not that backstory and I
don't want to put you to shame what did they say
in the pilot they just mentioned that she's the
daughter of Lucifer I'm not talking about that
visual imagery from the first episode well I I
I'm pretty sure it was in the I'm pretty sure
because that's how whatever anyway uh I don't
I I just want you to feel comfortable when you're
here to express yourself why are you what's going
on on right now what are you doing anyway uh I
don't know what I was going to say now I don't
feel shamed I feel uh empty-headed confused
no you were saying you were saying that in the
pilot first episode one of them that Lucifer was
portrayed I never thought he was gonna be evil or
a bad guy because that's not who Lucifer is um
but I did I didn't think he was going to be so
bumbling like in this he is he seems like out of
it weirdo I you kept saying how similar they were
I spit on you you kept saying how similar they
were I didn't see them to be similar really uh
at first because the state that we find him in
he seems like a like Spacey you call him a dead
be like just out of it doesn't really care about
anything just like in a in a depressed hole and
it kind of made me think when did that turn take
because then we just heard this backstory from
him that he also tried this and at what and we see
him carrying her when she's a kid but now we know
they're kind of a strange she talked to him five
months ago at what point then was he like F this
I'm out I can't keep trying I have no idea when
that point would be I think what I was saying
dead beat it was more that he feels like he was
a failure and I I feel like the episode really
demonstrated that throughout that and then when
you get to that song when he's saying I tried I
there's this impression you get that like I want
to unpack like what the lore and the Really the
the lineages of how Hell turned into what it is
now for Lucifer to end up here because people are
still you know he's still revered the The Legend
the myth of Lucifer is still talked about no one
just sees him and goes what a joke you know you
yeah that was a smart device when mit's like is
that Lucifer because we know like the even
strangers are like oh my God I'm in the room
with mixed company yeah yeah it's a it's a fun
way to do it what I am wanting uh from there's
a lot of other good things that happened in this
episode the one thing that I did that did dawn on
me here uh when it comes to Charlie's motivation
to help these people she keeps calling them my
people and I haven't unless I'm completely missing
something I haven't really gotten a sense of any
part of the community that feels like it's worth
fighting like when she says my people I I I'm like
why do you care about these people so much like I
you I never see her connect with any one outside
of who's at this hotel immediately never see her
with a sense of community never get any of that
to want to be like yeah you should go help but
she people she feels a kinship to them because
she is the princess of hell and we see it from
the beginning when she goes and she is on that
talk show and she announces the hasbin hotel and
while people aren't treating her well she still
knows that it's her job to try and help them live
the best lives and also she I think she feels like
they've been given a bad hand they're getting
executed and she's seen we when we do see her
with her girlfriend or with aliser who has such a
bad rep but she's taking him in or with um angel
dust like there's so much good in the in between
moments and I think she's seeing that but you're
right we haven't seen her like there's been no
like parade through the masses and I would like to
see her with more people to kind of see how they
read her we did see early on her go through the
streets remember yeah but there was no that first
song yeah we didn't see the dynamic of the people
to her like I don't know how everybody feels about
her yeah no one likes her yeah yeah it would be
nice to see like is that just that part of Hell
or like there outskirts of hell that are rooting
for her you know yeah that's the one one part I'm
craving I'm not saying like it's not within the
world is something I just would like to see it's a
it's akin to when you watch like a superhero thing
and you go well I want to see like the superhero
save some people so that way I get a sense of like
that's what really helps it feel heroic and when
it's specifically I'm specifically talking about
the lines of these are our people my people and I
don't see that connection that that's the one part
but I but it doesn't really matter honestly I'm
kind of like getting hung up on something that's
larger than yeah that's interesting it's working
for me because I feel like that's what she's the
entire point of the hotel is that she's looking
for the people to come there she wants them like
to want to get help but I do hear you it was
it's also Wilding my feelings apprciate it's
wild to go from episode four to episode 5 that was
I mean just totally just such a different shift is
this season done at six I think so so this was
the penultimate episode yeah I think so that's
crazy I need this to be a longer season right
right and that's why I'm I'm thinking about some
things that I'm wondering if we will get them but
as but with what we got here at least we got you
know the confirmation that vaggie and uh Charlie
her I know I was like man they never make it clear
in this episode we're girl we're dating aren't
you in bed with me we're this is my girlfriend
well they really laid it out for anyone who might
have been a little lost but imagine if we hadn't
dropped our first few episodes and had seen all
the comments of people being like that's girl
their girlfriend and girlfriend and then we just
got this we were like what yeah it's true well
um and then the last couple things aliser we're g
to find out hopefully find out next episode what
his true motivation really is I think he I want to
say he's my favorite character he is definitely my
favorite character just because I've never seen
anything like this where I do not trust him but
I love him and I'm going to be so disappointed
in him when he neverly lets us down and we find
out who his master really is or whose leash
he's on well he's always in such control and
he just resists to go all out like he loves a toy
with his food at all times he could easily just
probably snap his fing fingers and be done with
people but he he he he likes to let things just
in he has some ultimate plan but yet someone else
has power over him which I think is a smart thing
to do for your character I don't know what's going
to on with him but it seems it's quite intriguing
because hus did talk about him being on a leash
but he was he was having the whole thing with
uh Lucifer of I I did not pick up on all at all
about him you know viewing Charlie like his own
daughter and when that song came in I couldn't
tell that's just some manipulation ploy to push
re h on her I was like who at first I thought he
was hitting on her I was like I don't know what's
happening right now cuz it kind of came out of
nowhere to me the last thing I expect I that
to me I I don't I did not see that coming at all
and I feel like he was manipulating a situation
otherwise I think he would have been more upset
or they would have shown him being upset after
the fatherdaughter duet um final song that we got
I think it is possible I just I think that so far
he's had full free range over ruling Charlie in
this hotel and he knows that when her dad comes
in he's not the dad and that Lucifer can really
change things your instincts are better than mine
I thought vaggie was just his her friend so you
know and maybe you might be right there might
be some master plan here by aliser to get her
and Lucifer close and by making Lucifer jealous
aliser thought okay Lucifer's going to then
introduce her to the heavens that's that's what
I was think definely possible yeah but you don't
need to appease my weak man emotions I know what
you're doing you're just trying to make me feel
all right about how I feel when you know you're
right it's okay no I think it is possible it's
okay all right look I don't need to be plated
to I don't need to be I need to talk down to me
a little Sensi I'm not I'm not no I'm not not
sensitive no it's I'm a big boy it's lighter
than sensitive it's sensey sensei's cute a so
sensey I can do 30 push-ups in a row I know I can
see your let's go cheee I drink energy drinks I
drink energy I drink g- fuel uh I think you're
crashing it my dude hasb been hotel that's what's
up anyway guys we're done with this one anyway my
dudes we're done with this one and we'll see you
for episode six which is the finale of hasbin
hotel if you're not there then you're Square
bro Rox has been a workshop in this character yeah
and this is what four years of Groundlings will
get